thank you everyone can you guys hear me
in the back before we get going yeah
cool um I wanted to thank Pete and Julia
and John and the geek talk team for
having me here Thanks ebay for hosting
thanks everyone for coming hopefully I
can answer some of those questions about
which workflow engine you should use if
you're just getting started before I
really get into things I just wanted to
go through a few pieces of background to
make sure you guys know that I know what
I'm talking about even though that might
not be true and make sure we're all on
the same page about you know what is to
do what's a workflow what's a workflow
engine so real quick my background is
that I've been working with a dupe for
about four years now and I've
implemented a Hadoop stack at two
different companies on the the DevOps
infrastructure side maybe what you would
call data engineering and over those
couple of years I've worked with a bunch
of different systems including Apache
Uzi Luigi and the initial version of
azkaban those are three different
workflow engines so I've really seen
what's out there I've done some
contributions to some of the workflow
engines and hopefully i can give
everyone a really good overview of what
the pros and cons are of the different
systems so i wanted to make sure that we
just we don't need a real deep
understanding of what Hadoop is but I
just want to make sure that we had a
kind of basic idea
there are two parts to Hadoop first is
the distributed file system HDFS which
basically distributes your data across
all the nodes in your cluster and the
second part is a computation framework
in Hadoop 10 it's called MapReduce and
Duke to Otto it's also called MapReduce
but it runs on the system called yarn
not super important but basically Hadoop
is a way of farming out computation and
Counting a lot of things really fast a
workflow so it workflows bit basically a
stat a list of steps that you want to
perform and you want to perform them in
some order so for example I might want
to take a dump of my production
databases put them in HDFS so be step
one step two would be run a MapReduce
job to say clean up the data and then
step three might be a whole set of
operations that run in parallel to you
know count the data one way counted
another filter accountant so you're
basically mapping all these different
operations and you represent the
workflow as a dag a directed acyclic
graph and then a workflow engine is
basically a system that manages
workflows I'll let you create workflows
define workflows run workflows delete
workflows those types of operations so
to give you an idea of what a workflow
might look like I want to walk through
two different use cases and I think
these are really representative use
cases that pretty much everyone using
Hadoop is doing one of these two things
so the first one is kind of an analytics
data
we're house built on Hadoop that is your
you're ingesting a lot of log data these
become your fact tables you're taking
backups of your production databases and
these are becoming your dimensions that
you join with your fact table so your
log data let's say we're were amazon our
log data might be things like user view
to product user bata product and you're
going to just have a user ID in the log
data and then you would have a database
backup that you imported into your
system that would map a user ID to a
full user object that has all the
attributes you know about a user and
then from here you take your log data
here which is your fact table your
dimension data data and you can do
roll-ups so you might want to compute
things like how many for each product
how many users have viewed that product
and maybe you want to break it down by
geography so you you roll up your data
you count per user sorry per state per
user ID a per state per item ID how many
people have used it and you would you
would have all these different compu all
these different combinations of of
counts and you would then load this into
some low latency store and then you
would power your dashboard in and bi so
this could be something like simplest
case I just want to count how many users
are on my platform more complicated i
want to draw pretty graphs that show me
you know which states are the most
active which products are selling well
in which states that kind of thing and
if you're more of a visual person this
is my cheapo drawing of what it would
look like on the Left you're taking your
log your DB dumps putting them into
Hadoop and then you're running your your
compute your MapReduce jobs that are
aggregating the data
storing it out to your file system as
roll ups or cubes and then you have some
sort of export process that takes the
data to your analytics database and then
your tableau your teradata sorry not
tired your visualization software is
connecting to your analytics database to
power dashboards real-time and the
reason you have that analytics database
in there is that the MapReduce framework
is not fast enough it's not low latency
enough to actually power anything that
that user wants to wants to view and
we're seeing a lot of activity in the
Hadoop ecosystem to get rid of that last
step that pulls data into an analytics
database with things like Impala the
Stinger initiative adapt all these
different SQL on Hadoop implementations
so if you're a data engineer what you
should probably be asking yourself is
what happens if there's a failure in
this pipeline so there's a couple of
ways you can have a failure you can have
a total failure where step a ran and it
failed and nothing else downstream ran
from it you have a partial failure where
it ran but it only ran over a portion of
the data set so now everything
downstream from it is bad so like for
example let's say you're in two data
centers and you only actually got the
logs from one of the two data centers so
all your accounts are off by fifty
percent and the third type of failure
the third main type of failure is just
that it didn't run at all and maybe that
was because the data wasn't there when
it was supposed to be or the system that
is controlling what ran failed and no
longer exists or something like that
second use case Owen talk about is to do
what I'm calling Hadoop driven features
so people you may know which is the what
linkedin has and gives you a list of
like who it thinks you should connect
with is one example of this also if you
go to amazon they'll show you on the
homepage hey we think you should buy
this because you bought that those are
those are two types of like
collaborative filtering then there's
another class of like machine learning
where you're doing things like spam
detection or natural language processing
and it's a similar but not altogether
the same pipeline instead of putting
your data in an analytics database
you're usually loading it to some sort
of low latency scalable sharded database
often a key value store so again if
you're more visual this is what it tends
to look like you maybe are pulling in
some log data but oftentimes you're just
pulling data directly from your database
dumps and you're doing more expensive
calculations in Hadoop and you generate
these production data sets that then get
loaded to your production data store
that serves search track it serves
traffic to the production application
and in this case it's a little bit
different what happens if it fails a lot
of times it's okay to skip a day so if
the people you may know recommendation
recommendations don't get updated for a
day maybe some people don't see stuff
but it's probably not the end of the
world it's not like you're telling in
the analytics data warehousing side of
things it's not like you're telling the
CEO that half of that the daily actives
are half of what they should be it's
just you're breaking one feature or
you're just making one feature stale and
a lot of times these workflows tend to
be self-contained
so you don't have a whole lot of you
might not chain that a lot of them
together if you're calculated in friend
recommendations there's that isn't
feeding into something else it's just
feeding into the product and one other
thing is there are failures that don't
actually fail a job but you've somehow
created corrupt data so it's really
important to have some sort of check
that make sure the data hasn't changed
too much that it still looks like it
should okay so getting into work full
engines a little bit now almost everyone
and at least in my experience maybe this
isn't true for you get started with
using cron and it looks something like
this at 1am i'm going to import all my
data at 2am i'm going to run some really
expensive query and then at 3am queries
b c and d are consuming the data from
the really expensive query and they're
producing some sort of analytics data
set or production data set and this can
break a couple of ways but the most
common one is that the step at 1am fails
the step at 2am runs anyway the step of
3m runs ever anyway and now you don't
know what happened you're kind of well I
see the last step failed but you have to
go back through and figure out what went
wrong this doesn't doesn't scale past
I'm saying about 10 jobs and it really
doesn't scale if you have more than a
couple people because once you have 10
people all editing the same crontab
entry and trying to change things around
and figure out this dependency graph in
their head and the crontab you're in a
lot of trouble so you're working with
cron and you're like okay I realized
this a bad problem let's do something
about it and I think there are two
possibilities the first is that you say
all right a workflow engine can't be
that hard I'm just going to write it
myself and if you do step one you're
probably going to do step two anyway
which is you're going to look out there
and see what's available because you
realize that hey ready to workflow
engine actually is really hard and you
figure out which ones are available and
you probably try all of them least
that's what I've always done because you
don't really know what the best option
is there's so many options there Hadoop
specific workflow engines there are
general-purpose ones there's not roll
your own but use the library and try to
shoehorn it into an existing application
and it's really shoehorn because I feel
like every time you try out one of these
workflow engines you had all the stuff
that was mostly working and now you try
to make it run inside the workfile
engine everything breaks in 10 different
ways and a month later you finally get
your workflow to run again
so here are some things you should be
thinking about when you're trying to
figure out which work fall engine is
right for you how do i deploy it and how
do i upgrade it that's both the workflow
engine and the workflow definitions
themselves how do I test it how do i
test an upgrade how do i test a new
workflow because like i said this this
application might run fine from my
laptop but i try to run it inside the
workflow engine starts breaking for you
know you're in you're in java class path
hell or you have file handle limits who
knows once you have something up and
running how do you detect failure how do
you when something fails how do you do
bug it how do you find the logs you
might think this is a silly thing but
you know logging is easy but you'll
hopefully I'll show you there's a pretty
wide range of debugging options based on
which workflow engine you choose let's
talk about that partial failure I said
where you run over half the data if you
run over half the data and you need to
now rerun the workflow and everything
downstream of it how do you do that is
it easy is a manual is there some way to
automate it or conversely if I now have
six months worth of intermediate data
and I want to add a new column to the
data set how do I rerun you know the
past six months of data so that I have
everything I need I think this second
last one a lot of people overlook how do
you data tune from a relational database
I think most people start running most
people are either running like my sequel
or postgres on their front end or
they're taking data and loading it into
vertigo or red shift on the back end and
it can be a harder problem than you
might think and lastly how do you manage
or maintain a set of similar tasks so
you want to do the same thing on these
10 different data sets how do you do
that
sorry about the light gray here how do
you or let's talk about Uzi first it's
just just I have an architecture slide
for each of the workflow engines I'm
going to talk about Uzi Azkaban and
Luigi just to give you a flavor of like
how complex they are or how many era how
many pieces are talking to which pieces
basically there are three main parts in
newsy you have a server that is
responsible for launching jobs and also
detecting when data sets arrive in hdfs
you have a client which is responsible
for both the dotted line they're
uploading data to HDFS so with Uzis you
upload your job definitions to HDFS and
then you use the rest api to submit your
job to the uzi server and then the third
part is the stuff real clear but you
have a map task launcher for every
single workflow that you run so what is
e does is it says okay you want to run a
MapReduce job alright I'm going to
submit a job to the Hadoop cluster and
all that's going to do is the job is
going to run on the Hadoop cluster as a
single map task and it's going to spawn
the actual job that you want to run so
there's this level of indirection so
what's
in my opinion hopefully objectively the
good parts of your Z you have fantastic
community support basically every single
Hadoop distribution comes with Uzis and
it's part of the apache software
foundation you have lots of resources
online it's also that also means it's
integrated with a lot of different
software hue which is a front-end to
Hadoop it's Hugh stands for the Hadoop
user experience caldera manager which is
basically a software that helps you
deploy different pieces of software more
easily and apache ambari which is
similar to cloud our manager but an open
source project what else do we have h
catalog integration so h catalog is this
system that interacts with hive you
don't really need to know too much about
this but basically instead of pulling
the file system to figure out when data
is available you can subscribe to JMS
messages that h catalog publishes when
data becomes available so you're usually
workflow will run as soon as the data
becomes available you have SLA alerts
this is a new feature an easy for you
can say all right i want this workflow
this workflow should run in 30 minutes
and if it doesn't run in 30 minutes send
me an email you have vast integration
with the entire Hadoop ecosystem big
hive scoop the documentation online is
super detailed if you want to use the
easy rest api there's you know tons and
tons of documentation on every single
endpoint all the arguments all these
things and it has the the feature i was
talking a little bit about that was
talking about before where it launches a
map only job with a single map past that
then spawns
all the other jobs so that means that
you don't need a fleet of jaw of
machines to kind of act as the launchers
for all your tasks you're basically all
you need is the Aussie server and the
database backing it and then you can run
a as many MapReduce jobs as you want
with that said launch our jobs as map
tasks is also a bad thing it adds
complications so if you want to debug a
job that failed you now have to go about
four links deep in the the MapReduce API
or the MapReduce you I in order to
define the actual logs that describe
what happened in your job it tends to
hurt cluster utilization because you
have all these map tasks running that
are basically doing nothing other than
asking the jobtracker every 10 seconds
if the job that they launched is
finished or not
and I think that's there was one of the
things that I can't think they so the UI
to Uzi is also pretty horrendous but as
I said there there is Hugh and there's
also a project out of foursquare called
easy web that gives you a much nicer
front end too easy using the API that
Uzi exposes the barrier to entry to
Susie is extremely high we would have to
sit down with a developer and basically
walk them through you know coding out
how the definition for this workflow and
it would take you know a good day or two
just to define the workflow and then you
have to run it and that's another whole
complicated thing finally set up not
finally but also set up it's not just a
one of one button install you have to
download this EXT jsu have to set up the
new proxy user in the name node and the
jobtracker you need a relational
database and last of all some people
love XML but I absolutely hate it let me
rephrase humans shouldn't have to use
XML yes
yeah yes so there's a command line tool
that basically is a java application
that it's the api and the api is really
good so that seems to work pretty well
yeah I have us don't you can't really
see it it's really faded but the that's
the easy you I it looks like something
from web I don't know 20 but failed and
it's also really unresponsive there's
all kinds of Ajax calls without telling
you that something's happening and then
you click three times and now all of a
sudden you've issued three database
queries and it's like killing the day
anyway in terms of XML that also means
there's a lot of boilerplate so this is
what hello world looks like an Uzi I'm
really all you're trying to do here is
invoke a main method yeah so that's
pretty much all i had to say about Ozzie
Azkaban is a open source workflow engine
written by the folks at LinkedIn as i
said i use the the first version of it i
spend some time with Azkaban too and I
don't think there are a whole lot of
major changes i'll try to point out what
they are but hopefully i can still give
you some subject objective points about
the azkaban workflow engine so
architecture wise it's somewhat
different from newsy and that you still
have this centralized server but instead
of running jobs as map only MapReduce
jobs you have these X to azkaban
executor servers and they are the ones
that are submitting the jobs to the
Hadoop cluster and managing the state of
if the job is finished or not and it's
backed by my sequel and I think you can
also run with
either Derby or h2 I forget which one
and the other thing that's worth
pointing out in this architecture
diagram is that I have azkaban client
there in quotes and that's because
azkaban is very you I driven so you have
to go to a UI and upload a workflow go
to a UI and run a job go to you I and
schedule a job there are some options to
basically fake run the same request as
the you I would run via the command line
but it doesn't let you do things like
schedule a job or if it does it's a
little more complicated so with that
said the the good things about Azkaban
you could give a great UI you have
things like dag visualization task kick
history you can easily click through to
all the logs for any job anywhere give
this plug-in architecture and that gives
you access to all the stuff in the stack
the the pigs the hives and also an
integration with Baltimore and one of
the things that asked that LinkedIn
likes to point out about this plug-in
architecture is that it lets you run
multiple versions of Hadoop within the
same deploy of azkaban because you can
have a plug-in for version one a plug-in
for version two and everything like that
it also has SLA alerting it has a really
great HDFS browser so you can click
through from a job to its output and
then click a button and get the first 10
records it does converts avro files the
JSON so that you can you can view them
it has user authentication and
authorization it also is auditing so you
so if someone goes and changes a job you
can click through on the UI to to see
when it was changed and who did it and
there's this really cool feature that
has not yet been been merged called the
report ille which is basically a quick
version of a workflow so instead of
uploading a workflow to the Azkaban
server normally you define a Azkaban
workflow as a Java properties file that
says okay this is my main method this is
the type of the job these are the
dependencies things like that and then
you bundle jars with that properties
file and put it in a zip file and upload
it so the report all lets you get around
that if you just want to run a hive
query or a pig script you go to the
report all and you can paste in your
query and the job gets automatically
created and you can say run this once a
day email me etcetera so hopefully that
gets merged soon I think that'll be a
great feature
this is maybe not the best screenshot
but to give you an idea of like what the
Azkaban UI looks like it's it's
definitely much better than what usually
comes with out of the box there are a
few things that are not so great about
Azkaban you have you have this missing
notion of data dependencies so if you
think back to that chron example i have
where 1am you import log data at 2am you
run a expensive query that goes over the
log data you don't want that job at 2am
to run unless the log data is available
and you end up defining if you if you
want to represent those dependencies in
terms of tasks depending on task that
can become a very complicated thing to
represent because you might have your
log ingestion that runs every night and
then you might have 300 things that
depend on it and now you have to those
three hundred things that depend on it
have to know the name of the task that
does log ingestion so it's much nicer to
be able to represent this job should run
when this data is available kind of
thing another thing the the executors
run on separate machines it's not part
of Hadoop but maybe with with yarn which
once you schedule arbitrary jobs you'll
be able to run your your Azkaban
executor services as on the same nodes
as your Hadoop cluster terms of
community from what I've seen I'm kind
of a worker on the Azkaban list it seems
to be mostly used by linkedin and
version 2 was basically a code dump a
year after the version 1 code dump so
there wasn't like a whole it's not like
a patchy software project where
have people from all kinds of different
companies collaborating on it but with
that said the mailing list is super
responsive if you have a question you
send it off and you'll you'll probably
hear something within a day or two and
then for Azkaban I had a couple things
that were both good and bad so you're
defining your jobs as Java properties
files this is definitely simpler than
XML but it's also a little bit there are
some things that are hard to represent
as Java properties or if you have you
have to worry about escaping variable
names or things like that because there
are scape rules and Java properties
files or you can have a have a value
span multiple lines things like that web
uploads deploys that might be like
awesome for you that you go into the
Azkaban UI and you just upload you like
upload the zip file that says okay this
is how I this is the name of the job i
want to run for me I think that's a
terrible idea because you're basically I
could have built that code on my on my
local laptop and not checked anything
into source control and uploaded it and
if sorry first of all it wouldn't be me
doing that it would be someone else but
I would be the one to bugging it and I
don't know what's running so it might be
great for a lot of people but for me I
don't think it's it's good and it goes
along with running and scheduling jobs
if you want to integrate with
configuration management so you want to
define you have a definition of all your
workflows and you can have a staging
version in a production version and
they're identical all in like puppet or
chef or what have you it's really hard
to do with azkaban I did it when I was
working at edcon yin and
it was mostly possible but it was also
pretty a lot more complicated than then
it should have been so I last work for
lunch and I'm going to cover in any any
depth is Luigi and I Luigi comes from
from Spotify and we have some Spotify
folks here in the back if you have
questions afterwards also a good time to
point out that I feel really bad about
saying anything negative about anyone's
work full engine because I know there's
been a lot of hard work put into
everything I'm just trying to you know
give a fair overview of what we have
okay so here's the the Luigi
architecture you have a centralized
scheduler and you have a lot of workers
and the workers communicate with the
scheduler over a JSON rest api and each
worker has a copy of the code base and
Luigi you don't define your tasks as
properties files or XML files you
actually write a little python class to
describe your task so each worker gets a
copy of the entire code base which is a
copy of all of the tasks that it needs
to run and each will luigi worker talks
to each gfs and it walks the the
workflow dag and it says for each task
does the output exist yet and it uses
that information that it finds as its
walking the dag to figure out which
tasks need to be run and then after it
walks the dag it communicates with the
scheduler and the scheduler acts as a
locking mechanism so that you don't have
to job two of the same jobs running at
the same time
so the Luigi worker talks to the
scheduler and gets back some work and
then it actually runs the job via
MapReduce or hive or what have you so
what's good task definitions are code if
you need to do a for loop for some
reason you can do a for loop you're not
like trying to write a for loop in XML
tasks or item potent item potency means
that you can run the task you can run
the same task again and it won't break
anything it'll say this task has already
been run and it will gracefully exit so
that's a super helpful property
workflows define both the data
dependencies and the task dependencies
so what I was alluding to before if you
have like 300 tasks that all depend on
your log ingestion there's a there's a
relatively easy way to represent that I
think the community is growing it's by
far the easiest code base to hack on and
if you need to use if there's some
feature not and Luigi and you want to to
use it or you need this feature it's
pretty easy to add it has a nifty
postgres integration which when I was at
Foursquare we got this to work with with
loading data to both red shift and
vertica now the bad so it's missing a
few key features one that that stands
out is pig support I think honestly it
probably take about a day to add this
feature but no one's gotten around to it
yet the deployment situation is a little
confusing it took us a long time when I
was a foursquare to figure out how to do
the deployed correctly because you have
to get a copy of the code base
distributed to every worker but you also
don't want like half your workers run
one version of the code base and the
other half running another version or if
or if that does happen you want to you
want to be able to easily tell when a
job fails which version of the code it
was running and it's even though I said
it's like the worst thing ever the
poison Luigi are used cron which is also
a little counterintuitive the Luigi has
a great visualizer but it doesn't scale
to tens of thousands of nodes in your
pen see graph which it doesn't take take
much to get there and it's also not
backed by a relational database and the
scheduler does persisted state when it
gracefully shuts down but if it doesn't
gracefully shut down you you've lost the
state and you can you can have some some
data corruption issues if you bring back
up a new scheduler because all the
workers will try to rerun jobs they're
already running and lastly when when
Luigi walks the dependency graph it
checks for every task if the output
exists and the way that it does that is
by shelling out to the Hadoop come in
and it says Hadoop FS dash LS output
file and that there's a lot of JVM
overhead to do that you're talking like
three to five seconds for each task when
you're walking the dependency graph and
there are some ways around this but the
basic the the batteries included
implementation does have this this
limitation
so I put together some some comparisons
of these three workflow engines in my
own words tried to be as objective as
possible but the caveat at the very
beginning I have contributed to both
Azkaban and Luigi you can see one of the
things that definitely stands out is the
code complexity you're talking two
orders of magnitude difference between
Luigi and boozy so would you super easy
to hack on but if you find a bug in
newsy you better find a workaround it's
like super hard to get from the Lirin
off with the code base to to fix it this
is a lot of recap of what I talked about
before there's a little bit more on this
page property configuration can be a
total headache if you want all your jobs
to run with some production database
password you might think that's super
simple but you don't want to hard code
that into all the jobs because the next
time in employee leaves and you have to
you have to change that password then it
can be a huge pain reruns are also an
issue Uzi has a command-line interface
to rerun jobs I have to say this was a
couple versions ago but I could never
get the rerun stuff to actually work
Azkaban has a nice feature where if like
you know you have a 10-step long
workflow and the first eight steps
succeeded and the last two failed when
you rerun the job it will only run the
last two and Luigi since it's idempotent
it won't rerun a job unless you
explicitly delete the output of that
task
and other considerations if if you're
using if like security and authorization
or super important to you azkaban has
all the Dane has you can do you can
define all your your user authentication
in an XML file Uzi has Kerberos and the
equivalent of Hadoop simple where's
Luigi your you're running jobs as a
linux user so if you want to secure
would you know if you have a secure
Hadoop deploy then you can take
advantage of that by just running your
jobs as particular Linux users on your
gateway machines in your hairdo cluster
there's a couple a bunch of workflow
onions I didn't get to to go through you
might want to look into these they're
not as popular as the 3 i've mentioned
some of them are popular but in a more
general purpose setting for example if
you spring everywhere then spring batch
might be a great solution for for work
for luncheons for you ok so now I'm
going to take off my objective hat and
talk a little bit more about like my
personal feelings maybe give you an idea
of which work for lunch and I think you
should use if you haven't figured it out
already all right so first first one I
really like a that Luigi in particular
is a scripting language because what
happens a lot of times with all these
other work fall engines is that when you
want to run a one-off job to debug a
outside or test it to make sure that
everything works you actually end up
writing a bunch of scripts to run your
jobs anyway
and why not just use the scripting
language for your workflow engine at the
beginning and then you get all these
features for free so in Luigi when you
define a task you you can list out
parameters and then those become
available as command line options when
you're running your task automatically
and we found at Foursquare is when we
move to Luigi people instead of writing
these custom scripts would actually as
they were developing their MapReduce job
from the beginning would write a luigi
task to finding the MapReduce job and
its dependencies and then because it was
a it was easier to run your job that way
than it was to run it without Luigi and
you can also do things like you you want
to represent a seven day data dependency
well you just use a for loop and you say
alright it depends on these be seven
days and you return that in the requires
method of your task whereas if you want
to do something like that in guzzi it's
going to be a lot more complicated item
potency I think is super important if
you if you by default if you try to run
a MapReduce job and the output directory
already exists your job is going to fail
so it can be really misleading if you do
a rerun and all of a sudden something
fails because the output already exists
and the so the solution that a lot of
people do is the first step of their
MapReduce main method is to delete the
output and that's like super dangerous
because what if you rerun this job that
you didn't mean to and it like deletes a
data set that spend a year or something
like that so it's really nice to have
item potency to kind of take care of
this issue for you
I would have to it earlier what you see
is what you get when we started out with
Uzis we had all these jobs that were
that we're working and then we took them
and ran them inside of boozy and they
started failing for various reasons
classpath issues you you know you had to
you had to massage the job so that it
you can propagate properties in certain
ways it's really nice to be able to run
your job the same way in development as
you do once you're in production and
that's something that you could probably
build the right to tools to do that in
news e or ask a band but it's kind of
baked into Luigi and easy to hack on
pretty much any work full engine you
choose is not going to have all the
features you want that's why i said in
the very beginning you're going to take
your existing workflows and you're going
to try to shoot you harm them into
whatever workflow engine you pick so
being able to hack on it i think is
super important and to kind of give you
an idea of my bias in terms of things I
think are less important
high-availability you know if if the
workflow engine crashes on a Saturday
I'm okay with you know within six or
twelve hours intervening and bringing up
a new new instance of the workflow
system I don't really care about
supporting multiple clusters I'm not
running like 10,000 or you know a
hundred clusters so I'm running two or
three so i can bring up an instance of
the workflow scheduler for each cluster
i'm running and i've never used the
hadoop security features so if that's a
high priority for you then there might
be all kinds of issues with Luigi and
you might want to use easy because it
has that stuff built in
last slide just some like words of
wisdom in terms of best practices with
whatever work 400 you choose I like the
idea and I haven't done this in a while
we did it at my previous job when I like
the idea of versioning data sets so
let's talk about you have some data set
that has nine columns in it and you want
to add a tenth column what you could do
is you take Joe's data set and you
delete the past year of data and you
rerun it and you produce the new data
with ten columns the other option is you
version your data set so you have joe's
data set version 1 and that's like
encoded in the URL of your data in HDFS
or s3 or wherever you're storing it and
and then when you into backfill you are
writing to a different directory and
after your back Phil is done you can
clean up garbage clock the old data this
is one that always bites everyone so you
set up monitoring for when a job fails
but there's this other type of failure
where which is basically the job doesn't
run so you need to monitor say you I
kick graphite whenever job finishes and
then you look for the fact that a job
hasn't finished within the past 36 hours
and you fire an alert if that happens or
something like that and you hear a lot
about continuous deploy for websites for
user facing features and I don't think
I've ever heard anyone talk about
continuous deploy for Hadoop and we did
an experiment where we where we had
continuous deploy for Luigi at
Foursquare and I think it's a good
practice but you also need a lot of
testing in order to really pull it off
well so if you have like a staging
cluster that is a subset of the data and
you can smoke test your entire workflow
I think continues to
is great and I'd like to I'd like to
bring up that as a conversation point I
I think that it's grew it always stinks
when you you have code that you
committed three months ago and it
finally gets deployed and you're working
on something completely different and
now you have to go back into bug it
right you want something to be out there
the next day so it's still fresh in your
mind you're not doing these context
switches let's see resources I'll post
the slides online and I so you guys can
grab these links I found a few few talks
on on each of the frameworks they're all
pretty good and that's all I have thank
you and I'm happy to answer questions